is set for a second term as Zimbabwe's
president
yes the Electoral commission says he won
53 of the vote with 44 for his main
Challenger Nelson chamiza the opposition
is rejecting the result though saying it
was rushed without proper verification
the general election on Wednesday was
extended by 24 hours after ballot papers
failed to arrive on time in some areas
like to you my fellow captain man and
women
once again himself as president
of a great country Zimbabwe
there is much more work to be done
together as one United people we shall
continue on the growth trajectory
witnessed
over the last five years
Let's cross to Harare Harry Matassa
joins us live from there and Harrow is a
controversy over the election results
what can we expect to hear from the
opposition
well what is Nelson jamisa going to do
now that's what a lot of zimbabweans are
asking we're at the party headquarters
where he's been to address a press
conference in a few minutes but on
Twitter he's been saying that this was
ablated and gigantic fraud he's told the
supporters not to lose hope and party it
feels are saying what they're doing
right now is uh in parts of the country
where they are they're collecting all
their votes their independent tallies
they're putting them together they're
together they're adding them they're
authenticating them and then they'll
release their own independent tally when
they're ready and they say this tally
shows that they won the election that's
why they saying that they feel this
election was stolen
what option though does the what options
do the opposition actually have
well most of Barbies I think there's a
sense that people know that street
protest is not much appetite for them
because the police here tend to clap
down hard on demonstrations so people
are expecting him to go to court but of
course what evidence does he have to
prove that the selection was stolen as
his party suggests there have been some
logistical challenges and also in some
cases the party officials say they have
not been able to access certain parts of
the country which are zanu PF
strongholds so they may not be able to
get information from those particular
areas so what will he take to court back
in 2018 when that election was disputed
he told Zimbabwean he had all the
evidence he needed to challenge the
disputed election the Court ruled that
he did not have the necessary documents
to prove that that election was stolen
so people are waiting to see first of
all today one is he going to court and
two does he have the evidence to tell
the country or to prove to the country
that the election was rigged all right
Haru thanks very much back with you as
we hear from jamisa a little bit later
well Amazon manager is Zimbabwe's second
democratically elected president since
independence from White minority rule in
1980 came to power following the coup
which deposed long-time leader Robert
Mugabe back in 2017. manager is
nicknamed the crocodile that's for his
reputation during fighting between
zanopf and another party dominated by
the in the ballet Community up to 20 000
of them were killed during conflict
during the conflict in the 1980s at the
time Managua was national security
minister in charge of the intelligence
wing of the army Gaga denies overseeing
the killings so let's take this on we
can speak to farai marapira who is
director of information and publicity
for the zonu PF party joins us now from
Harare and great to have you with us
appreciate your time so to me is a the
opposition candidate he says it's a
blatant and gigantic fraud his voters
should not lose hope what do you say to
that
well thank you for that
um
Mr shamisa is replaying um the same game
that he played in 2018.
on the 24th of July he came out in a
headline on the Newsday uh one of uh uh
private private newspapers here in Zim
saying that there is no way that uh the
election could be rigged
and it was headline news and now they've
changed their stance and they're saying
that uh some really might have happened
so as npf our
personal uh correlation of results are
tallying with uh with what Zeke has said
if Mr Chamisa has got any challenges
with uh the results is very free to
visit the courts and a secret dress from
the courts okay well we'll hear from
what from what Mrs hear what he has to
say shortly but he's not alone in his
views is he because International
observers say that the vote fell short
of democratic standards
well I don't know
um if we can say all International
observers because the Indian election of
observers have been in support of come
out in support of uh the election and
they've found them credible
um it's quite daunting that you find
that people want to say that there is a
major challenge with elections simply
because
um on the voting day less than one
percent
um of the polling stations uh fail to do
their voting and through a presidential
Proclamation the very next day everyone
was of accorded the chance to do their
voting so some of the allegations that
they're leveling uh towards us trying to
discredit the election with audio
respect as periods but um we respect
opinions and um we'll look at the
opinions we'll take what is good we will
live off what is bad we keep on
developing ourselves as a democracy okay
but what if locals not everyone comes to
whatever local vote monitor is being
arrested local vote monitors being
arrested in a ruling party affiliate
organization taking details of people
walking into voting booths that's voter
intimidation isn't it
well
to to to to the best of my knowledge a
lot of countries in the world do exit
Falls
and besides uh there's nothing illegal
it's unfortunate that is only in
Zimbabwe uh if eggs impos are conducted
it becomes a scandal
um it it plays to the concept of having
people with the agendaism instead of
objectivity
um
any these exit polls are not occurring
within 300 meters of any polling station
these were occurring more than 300
meters outside of the polling station
so I really don't understand how exit
polls uh can be considered as a voter
intimidation it's um only in Zimbabwe
nowhere else
[Music]
if Jimmy doesn't like to go to courts
how long will that process take would
you say
um
I can't speak on behalf of the courts or
their processes but I know that we've
got an electoral courts and uh if you
look at the whole electoral process how
it has been moving uh cases have been
attended to swiftly
um this is a born on the back of uh
reforms that have been done by uh
president himself that now our court
processes move faster so if they go to
courts their their case will be heard as
quickly as possible we believe in that
and if they really do have any
challenges or anything that they feel is
unfair with how the election has been
run that's why the courts are there we
encourage them to go to the courts uh
not uh the cause of public opinion now
with unproofing things they're very very
welcome to go to the courts we encourage
them to actually go to the courts if
they feel they've got any case to
present the thing is Mr maripita there
is no doubt that the elections were
delayed they were marred by delays which
which is fueled the accusations of
rigging and voter suppression and that's
been a real problem isn't it
well when you say um uh when less than
one percent of polling stations and wads
face a bit of a delay then you say uh
the whole election was mugged by delays
um that's a bit on the side of hyperbole
with Ojo respect every election is gone
it's a human process there are errors
that are made there are challenges that
come some foreseen and someone to
foreseen remember most of these delays
occurred in places where there had been
electoral challenges almost through the
day of election so we can understand on
behalf of their I don't speak for Zach I
speak for Xanax but we can understand
that Zack had challenges because there
was really not much of the time to print
in these particular places you look at
the places there were challenges now um
you find the opposition saying why were
there no delays in some rural areas is
because there were no Electro cases
before the courts so areas that were
mainly affected with areas that had
illustrial cases before the courts and
these uh cases are LED right up to the
eve of actions this is what uh in my
opinion because the delays and the
printing and uh all Associated
challenges that came from uh from that
issue
when finally Mr muripitter when the head
of the EU Observer Mission says that the
election took place in a climate Affair
do you think is he just making it up
um
um you know if you look at all most of
the observers they've spoken of a
peaceful election and the issue of
intimidation and fear I don't understand
where he's coming from
um the opposition has been conversing
for votes everywhere
they've been moving as freely as
possible and there's been literally no
no violence there's no violence to talk
about if we look at uh our other company
our countries have done their elections
we've had uh the most peaceful of
Elections so the the justification for
uh for intimidation I I would really
love to see how they can justify such an
allegation in their final report because
we've really had very peaceful elections
very little violence so what medium of
intimidation was used I'm very curious
to also see when they present their
final report
we appreciate you joining us here in Al
Jazeera it's
the director of information publicity
for the zonu PF party thank you
thank you so much for having me